[Applause]
hello
yes it's time for drew's news your sick
riff on that good news guitar
and with me at the desk is a rock star
of news programs rossi and ross matthews
yes
drums
hi
i love air everything guitar uh-huh face
this is air tambourine hey
that i'd be that girl in the band i
wouldn't i'd be the tambourine girl no
musical doll in here but lots of musical
appreciation of course oh my rossi i
love you thank you i have to say it is
bring your fiance to work day it is
wellington my fiance is in the courtroom
i know oh wally i'm so happy to see you
okay first up we're going to get right
in and talk about how to make social
media a better place
insider reports meghan markle has one
suggestion
she thinks that instagram should add a
dislike button she says it would allow
people to show they disagree without
having to pile on more and more negative
comments she and harry famously quit
social media after all the toxic
messages harry recently cited one
interesting report that found 70 percent
of the hate speech aimed at megan came
from just 50 accounts really
it's you know what this made me realize
also is
um
if i was to try and find some positive
aspect of this that i thought that maybe
instead of everybody going bananas and
being mean to each other maybe these
smaller sources are just getting blown
up out of proportion and seeming like
the bigger picture when if you get down
to the root of the root and the bud of
the bud maybe it's a little more narrow
and not so widespread the negativity so
i thought
as much as this was so illuminating um
maybe it goes to show that there is not
as much vitriol out on the planet maybe
it's coming from smaller sources and
sort of you know getting blown out of
proportion like it's a small negative
minority who's just real loud i think
that's what my naive optimistic you know
happy positive person wants to believe
but that is a fascinating stat i would
have not guessed that no well i want to
quote the great taylor swift hater's
going to hate hate hate
no matter what you do
the thing
about a dislike button is it to me it
feels like a welcome mat for negativity
it's you know again it's too many
options like like or just like
people are negative enough online you
know what i'd rather have a dislike
button a big old block button because if
you come at me and you're negative peace
out goodbye
yes you can block people yeah but it's
like a three-step process they're like
are you sure you want to block them have
you thought about it are you really sure
girl i'm sure
um bye-bye
bye-bye okay ross your story here is our
next story about uh the two most well
going from negativity to now the most
disliked colors of paint uh out there
oh hate on page yes but we're going to
see what you guys think because
apartment therapy reports that according
to a new survey by modsi which is an
interior design service the least
desired paint colors for your home
are orange and pink huh i know i'm sorry
to orange and pink we still love you we
do but but people just don't want you
all over their walls
they say orange is too closely
associated with traffic cones
i kind of see it in that shade of orange
just a little bit and that pink is a
little too pepto-bismol you know
well i'm gonna disagree there is a way
to work with any color and you can also
use it as trim or accent but i wouldn't
negate uh orange or pink in fact i
painted a kitchen pink i'll show you
some pictures of it i love this yeah yep
that's i went real kitschy and funky
because there was pre-existing tile that
someone thought i know i'm gonna do
racer like
nascar
strike through bright green tile thank
you to the previous owner
um and so i just wanted to work around
that i wasn't i didn't want to demo the
kitchen i don't have that ability right
now one day i'd like to attack this
kitchen so instead i got some pink paint
and some wallpaper and it was like green
and dark and i just changed the whole
thing with wallpaper and paint that's a
cheap way to make a huge difference in
the house i like to say don't renovate
innovate thank you so much
i
i'm so inspired by your your use of
color and paint because you know i when
it comes to like clothes i'll wear
anything sequins velvet i'm like share
at the oscars okay just put it on me bob
mackey thank you but interior you've
seen pictures of my house it's like
white and stark and it's like an our art
gallery but like if it were up to me
it'd be boring so i'm so inspired by you
looking at a kitchen and thinking pink
okay will you help me redo like my
master bedroom or something oh my god
really would you really i just did your
dressing room yes okay help me tackle
[Applause]
stay tuned for pictures
okay next we've got a story for all
those
good boys and girls out there yes i'm
talking to all the doggies watching
drew's news
so the good news network reports that a
dad in new zealand just opened a stick
library for dogs in his neighborhood you
know people put out books for people to
get well andrew taylor he noticed that
there were very few sticks at the local
park so he cut some from his backyard
and he made a stick box and brought it
to the park with a sign that says stick
library please return he's the fairy
godfather of fetch
when i rossy something like this
it just
makes me have all that faith and
you know uh life-affirming inspiration
that i need and seek from humanity i
know like as a human being think to
yourself have you ever been as happy as
a dog looks with a bone like when's the
last time you were like
just so happy that something made you
that purely blissful you know and if it
needs it takes a stick to do it for a
dog then get him a stick all right next
we've got a man with a food plan that it
might make him a financial genius i
couldn't believe this the new york post
reports dylan from santa clarita managed
to save thousands of dollars by eating
all of his meals at the local six flags
theme park drew because here's the
here's how it worked it turns out the
santa clarita diet is not body parts
it's burgers and churros
starting in 2014 dylan paid 150. for an
annual pass it's a lot of money right
but he noticed that it included two free
meals a day the first year he never even
went grocery shopping he just timed it
out on the six flags diet dylan paid off
his loans got married and bought a house
with all the money he saved
really he would time it he could go
there twice a day and get free lunch so
he would schedule his lunch and dinner
while the park was open and he'd go
there and eat up to three to four times
a week he'd have the churros the hot
dogs
if i was eating at six flags my weight
would be like a roller coaster but
this man is a genius thousands of
dollars he saved he is they want to make
sure he gets some metamucil and a whole
bunch
and a whole bunch of vegetables
but yeah they don't really have a kale
sandwich yeah yeah i'm sure i'm sure
they do have sensible options though
um
my question is is six flags gonna hear
about this yes and change protocol
well i hope not because i could eat
churros for a year i don't know about
you
sign me up
well
speaking of fried foods before we go we
have a pick from the little yellow book
which is our personally curated list of
stuff
that we love
and we hope that you can get into too
it's just stuff we think you know what
would be so nice if we shared this
information and maybe somebody else
liked it okay so
this week i'm very excited um i follow
trader joe's food reviews on instagram
anybody else that's right it's so
amazing so of course i came across the
fact that they are making
hash browns
so for just a dollar 99 for a pack of 10
golden beauties from trader joe's
they're crispy they're delicious mushy
and melty on the inside just like you
like them yum okay
um show of hands who likes mcdonald's
hash browns
uh just about everything this is really
giving me that flavor
oh my gosh we'll be right back these are
amazing
[Music]
you